low-wage workers drove the record
voluntary quit rates that define the
early days of the great resignation
switching to better jobs in industries
raising wages
and they're coveted in the current
split-screen job market where job
opening rates remain highest in the food
service hospitality and health care
sectors while layoffs mount among higher
paid workers in fields like finance and
tech
a recent report found that employers
place too much priority on intangible
benefits such as employee recognition
time off and bigger job titles
the last of which ranked among the
bottom five priorities for frontline
workers but was near the top for
surveyed managers
in another example of a disconnect
employers ranked supportive managers as
the most important aspect for career
advancement while frontline workers
ranked it fifth
that could reveal managers own
presumptions that low-wage workers value
the same things they do
sarah wassertale managing director at
cara plus said quote
the nature of frontline roles tend to be
much more production related oftentimes
the incentives of the manager are
focused on you've got to go do your job
versus are they checking in on their
team
the report reinforced the fact that
hourly workers are ambitious to move up
the ladder but two-thirds of frontline
workers surveyed said they don't know
how to do it
the number was even higher among women
younger workers and those without a high
school degree
as employers remove college degree
requirements from jobs that don't need
them that increases the importance of
investing in upskilling programs to move
workers into higher roles and removing
barriers to unemployment for
underutilized groups such as those with
a criminal record giving extra support
to those who need it most has more
impact than employers may realize
the report found that frontline workers
who had previously been homeless or been
involved in the criminal justice system
are 14 to 16 percentage points more
likely than the average front-line
worker to devote non-work hours to
improving their skills
employers and front-line workers did
agree that pay and job growth
opportunities were the top priorities
but the information channels and
awareness of opportunities were quite
different
41 percent of managers used company
websites to share information about
career advancement while only 17 of
frontline workers said they used such
channels
that lack of awareness and access can
extract a high cost
32 percent of employers said they
offered tuition or outside education fee
reimbursement but only 15 percent of the
workers surveyed were aware of such
benefits
workers at all levels want more tools
and opportunities to advance their
careers
getting a shout out from the boss or a
gift card pales in comparison to online
classes coaching or real promotions that
come with more responsibility and
tangible increases in pay
[Music]
you